Salut ! Aujourd'hui j'ai une tête de malade, parce que je suis malade et on pourrait même dire que j'ai une tête de zombie...
Oui mais les zombies ça n'existe pas !
Si ça existe !
Ce n'est pas tout à fait comme on l'entend mais il y a une explication rationnelle au fait que les zombies existent vraiment et d'où vient cette légende.
Générique !
[musique]
Pour les haïtiens et les haïtiennes le vaudou ça existe réellement.
Nous en Europe on a tendance à pas trop y croire parce qu'on associe ça à de la magie noire.
Mais en fait les premiers vaudous, ceux qui existaient, peut-etre que ça existe toujours aujourd'hui,
ressemblaient plus à une planification d'esclavagisme qu'a un rituel vaudou.
C'est Wed Devis qui etait chercheur au museum d'histoire naturelle de New York qui a mené toute une enquete là-dessus.
Il était un peu passionné de tout ça, et un jour il y a un haitien qui est mort qui s'appellait Narcisse, et qui a réapparu quelques jours après.
Ça lui a permis de creuser le sujet, de faire une enquête là-dessus, de publier ça en 1987.
Et aujourd'hui ça nous permet à nous de mieux comprendre comment là-bas on arrivait à fabriquer des zombies.
Ce cher Narcisse meurt. Donc c'est un haïtien, il décède et il se réveille à un moment donné dans un cercueil sous la terre, complètement paralysé.
Il entend qu'il y a du bruit au-dessus, on le déterre et là c'est un sorcier vaudou qu'il déterre, qui lui explique qui lui a rendu la vie grace à un rituel vaudou.
Il lui fait prendre une petite boisson, une petite potion, pour qu'il aille beaucoup mieux.
Et Narcisse se retrouve un petit peu... un petit peu dans le brouillard mais en tout cas, en vie, en train de bouger, et il doit la vie aux sorciers.
Le sorcier l'envoie à la plantation, pour travailler gratuitement, pour lui. Plutôt malin le sorcier !
En le menaçant que de toute manière si il ne s'exécute pas, si il ne fait pas le travail, alors il lui reprendra la vie qui lui a rendu.
Il est plutôt malin le gars quand meme !
Ah c'était pas Uber mais il avait quand même une bonne stratégie du travailles pour moi et... je prends un bon pourcentage.
100% en fait !
Au cours de son enquete W. Devis a pu approcher de très près les potions en fait qui permettaient de rendre la personne morte.
Ou simili morte et de la réveiller.
Et il s'est aperçu qu'au milieu de toutes les plantes, l'ingrédient principal c'était le fougou, le poisson globe.
C'est le poison qui a dans le poisson globe qu'on prépare dans les restaurants et d'ailleurs qui malgré toute une quinzaine de personnes par an
tellement le poison il est 20 ou 50 fois plus fort que le cyanure, je ne sais pas le chiffre exactement mais il est beaucoup plus fort que le cyanure.
Et surtout il contient une neurotoxine hépatite, donc bien doser dans le savant mélange ça permettait de rendre une personne pas décédée
mais comme si elle était décedée, qu'un médecin puisse constater le décès.
Puisque de toute manière elle était inconsciente , paralysée, etc.
Pour pouvoir la réveiller plus tard.
Il préparait toute une potion avec ce poison là, il dosait ça et il en faisait une poudre qui mettait dans les chaussures directement de la personne qu'il visait,
Et comme ça avec la transpiration etc, ça passait par les pores de la peau, ça s'infiltrait dans le sang et on croyait juste à un décès complètement classique.
Ensuite le sorcier allait à la tombe.
Il déterrait la personne qui avait reprit conscience mais qui était toujours un peu paralysée.
Il lui faisait boire une potion qui était à base du duboisia.
Alors le duboisia c'est une plante de la famille de la datura qu'on trouve dans les jardins français d'ailleurs.
Et cette plante est bourrée d'atropine et de scopolamine.
Ce qui en fait un antidote naturel du poison du poisson globe.
"Du poison du poisson globe"... c'est pas si simple à dire !
On a en plus découvert récemment qu'il y avait un peptide à l'intérieur.
C'est un ensemble d'acide aminé on va dire, qui fait un peu flanchir la mémoire et qui a tendance à rendre la personne un peu plus docile.
Le sorcier faisait donc boire ça parce que ça faisait un antidote et ça rendait la personne un petit peu smooth.
Aujourd'hui on sait tout ça parce que Narcisse s'était échappé de la plantation et c'est ça qui a mis la puce à l'oreille dans les année 80 à Wed Devis,
qui en plus a eu la chance d'avoir un contact avec un enquêteur qui lui savait quel était le remède de ce poison.
Voilà donc a quoi servait ce rituel vaudou.
En fait ça servait simplement à crééer des esclaves qui allaient travailler dans les plantations et en faisant passer ça pour de la magie,
eux meme après n'osaient pas contredire le sorcier.
Et vous l'avez compris... c'était le dernier hors sujet également de cette année.
Mais comme j'ai une tête et une voix de zombie aujourd'hui, je me suis dit que c'était tout à fait approprié !
Merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo !
Pensez à la liker et à vous abonner si elle vous a plu.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
[musique]